Film Courage: Do you think a lot of people
who come here [to Hollywood] realize maybe
how empty some of that is?
If you get the acclaim of many people and
you have the possessions [you will be happy]?
That a lot of times it’s in the beauty of
doing the work, it’s not in what “they
say.”
Katherine Brooks: I think everyone has their
own personal journey.
I do believe that from working with all the
celebrities I’ve found that people that
are the most famous, are the most lonely.
And I think we all go through a personal journey
about trying to understand what’s really
important to us and what we want for our lives.
And for some people that might be fame and
fortune and that’s fine.
But I don’t think that is what fulfills
the soul.
That the art and the love and the compassion
and the empathy, I think those are the things
that fill that artistic craving more than
accolades or money and fame.
Film Courage: I am wondering why that would
be for someone who has so many people who
wants access to them and want to be in the
same room with them and feel totally alone
[in a huge crowd of adoring people]?
How does this happen?
Katherine Brooks: I think what happens is
that you have so many people when you are
a public figure that think that they know
you, especially if you’re really open in
the press, open about your life.
So these people that want to meet you think
that you’re their friend or…And the truth
is that you’re working so much.
So if you’re working 13 to 15 hours a day.
You don’t really have much time for a life
outside of your work.
And then you have all of these people who
want a piece of you or who think they know
you.
And that can even drive you into isolation
even more because you’re not understanding
sometimes ‘Why do they feel like they know
me?’
Or ‘Why do they want to be so close to me?’
So, it’s scary sometimes.
Then other times, it’s such a beautiful
thing to have people feel like they know you
and be around you.
It’s kind of a double-edge sword in a way.
I appreciate both sides of it because I have
such supportive fans.
I love them.
But at the same time, when I was at my darkest
moment, when I was about to make FACE TO FACE,
no one was there with me, I was completely
alone.
So…it’s two sides of the coin really.
Film Courage: I remember seeing Lionel Ritchie
in public one time [Editors note: waiting
for his car at a valet] and then I went up
to him and said “Love your work.”
And kept it at that and moved on.
Is there a right way to approach someone in
the public eye or do you kind of gauge it
and see is it appropriate for me to even go
up to this person?
Katherine Brooks: I think going up to public
figures, there’s a couple of things 1) It
depends on what setting they are in.
I think when people are having dinner or they
are having a personal conversation and just
going up and like interrupting them and being
like ‘Oh my Gosh, love you!
Can I have your autograph?”
I think that you have to be respectful and
sometimes there’s just that right moment
where you see someone where you really respect
their body of work and it just seems like
the right time.
I think you should always be yourself.
I think if you’re going to gush over them,
gush over them, don’t try to act like you’re
not or just like say your peace and say how
much you respect them and love them and move
on from there, you know?